استضافت العاصمه الايرانيه طهران اجتماعا
تشاوريا بشان الازمه السوريه حضره ممثلون
عن 30 دوله كان ارفعها تمثيلا الوفد
العراقي الذي شارك على مستوى وزير
الخارجيه بينما اكتفت اغلب الدول المشاركه
ومن بينها الصين وروسيا وسوريا بالتمثيل
على مستوى
السفراء
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين لماذا انتظرت ايران كل هذا الوقت
قبل الدعوه الى هذا الاجتماع وما دلالات
مستوى الاستجابه له وما فرص نجاح اجتماع
تهران في توفير حل للازمه السوريه التي تت
فاعل منذ 17
شهرا تاخرت نحو عام ونصف العام قبل ان
تبدا نشاطها الاول ضمن جهود الوساطه لحل
الازمه السوريه التي لطالما اعلن الهران
وقوفها المستمر في اطارها الى جانب النظام
السوري
929 دوله قبلت المشاركه في اجتماع تهران
لكن ايا من هذه الدول باست العراق لم
تشارك باكثر من مستوى السفير او القائم
بالاعمال امر يثير الى جانب عوامل عديده
اخرى يثير الكثير من التساؤلات حول فرص
نجاح مثل هذا
الاجتماع الازمه السوريه لم تبلغ نقطه لا
عوده والفرصه للوصول الى حل سياسي يوقف
نزيفها لم تفت بعد قناعه اقام عليها
اجتماع طهران اشغاله التي انطلقت اليوم
الخميس بمشاركه وفود عن نحو 30 دوله جاءت
تبحث كما تقول عن بصيص امل في حمل نظام
دمشق ومعارضيه على الجلوس الى مائده
الحوار وزير الخارجيه الايراني علي اكبر
صالحي في كلمته الترحيبيه بالوفود
المشاركه قال ان المؤتمر تاكيد لجهود
المؤمنين بان مساعده الشعب السوري على
تخطي محنته تمر حتما عبر حل سلمي يقود
اليه حوار بين اطراف النزاع في سوريا على
حد قوله لكن ظلالا من الشك حامد حول قدر
اجتماع طهران على تحقيق اهدافه المعلنه
فمستوى الوفود المشاركه بدا متواضعا وكثير
من الاطراف ذات التاثير المباشر في الازمه
قاطعت الاشغال فضلا عن المعارضه السوريه
التي ترى في ايران طرفا في الازمه لا يصلح
للعب دور الوسيط فيها موقف لاح قريبا من
تلك التي صدرت عن جهات غربيه اعتبرت ان
مؤتمر طهران ليس سوى محاوله ايرانيه لصرف
الانظار عن وقائع الارض حيث تستمر قوات
النظام السوري في التنكيل بمعارضيه وجدت
ايران نفسها في قلب الازمه السوريه مضرات
فيها التفافا غربيا اسرائيليا على الربيع
العربي مجدده في كل مره التاكيد على
تحالفها المتين مع النظام البعثي هناك ما
شجع جماعات مسلحه على اختطاف ايرانيين في
سوريا اشتباها في دعمهم لقوات الاسد موقف
تمسك به رئيس المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني سعيد جليلي في كل محطات جولته
التي شملت سوريا ودولا معنيه باز تها
مثيرا السؤال حول الحظوظ الواقعيه لايران
في ان تنجح حيث اخفقت الجامعه العربيه
والامم المتحده لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا
في الاستديو الدكتور غسان شباني رئيس قسم
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه بمونت
الامريكيه كذلك انضم الينا من طهران مصيب
النعيمي الكاتب والخبير في الشؤون
الايرانيه من لندن غسان ابراهيم المعارض
السوري المستقل وايضا هو مدير الشبكه
العربيه العالميه للدراسات اهلا بكم م
جميعا سيد نعيمي ضيفي من
طهران كيف ترى الاستجابه لهذا الاجتماع
التشاوري في ايران حتى سوريا كان تمثيلها
على مستوى
سفراء بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لا شك بان
اجتماع تهران كان تشاوريا بحث والحديث ان
ايران توقفت هذه الفتره لاجتماع هذا غير
صحي لان ايران كانت دائما داعيه للحوار
السلبي والحل السلبي لان الذين يحرضون على
الحرب والعمل العسكري في سوريا لا يريدون
الا الخراب والدمار لهذا البلد ومضى الان
اكثر من 17 شهرا ولن تنجز شيء فنعتقد بان
السبيل الوحيد والنهائي هي التي يمكن
الشعب السوري للحل الداخلي دون تعرض
الموضوع للامور خارجيه وكما نعرف هناك
تدخلات خارجيه غير واقعيه تحرض وتد البلد
دون ان ينجز للشعب السوري شيئا فهذا موقف
ايران كانت ثابت ودائم رغم محاولات لان
يعني يدخل ايران في متاهات التي هم وضعوها
فعلى الاموم اعتقد ان هذا الاجتماع بعد
هذاه المرحله على العصيبه تعتبر خطوه مهمه
صحيح وتشاوري قد تنقل جميع
الوفود مشاورات اليوم الى بلدانهم ويجب ان
يكون هناك تحركا جديا بعد ذلك حسب راي
الايرانيين ام
تقول ايران ترى هذه الخطوه مهمه وفي
مكانها ولكن هل ايران هي
الجهه الافضل لكي تقيم هكذا اجتماع وهي
التي تنحاز لجانب النظام
السوري
اي ايران لا تنحاز الى اي طرف بل ايران
تنحاز الى واقع المنطقه هناك معسكرين
واضحين معسكر تديرها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
معتده هنك هنك م هنالك ثوره سوريه في
الداخل والنظام تقول
مع معسر الاسرائ
الامريكي عن اسرائيل ولا عن الولايات
المتحده اتحدث عن مساله اعلان ايران انها
تقف الى جانب النظام النظام النظام
السوري ير المعركه والبقيه هم غير جنود
جنود مجانا لامريكا لتدمر اسرا سوريا
لتنقص الموقع سوريا في مواجهه اسرائيل ليس
الا ذلك لان ما في شيء اخر ونعرف فايران
ليس بامكانه ان تكون في معسكر الامريكي
طيب لا ادري ما الذي حشر اسرائيل الان
بالموضوع انتقل الى ضيفي من لندن غسان
ابراهيم س استاذ ابراهيم كيف تنظر الى هذا
الاجتماع التشاوري في
ايران ممكن اعاده السؤال لو سمحت كيف
تنظرون انتم كمعارض سوريه الى دعوه ايران
لهذا الاجتماع التشاوري وما خرج عنه عبر م
قاله صالحي نعم نعم يا سيدتي حقيقه كان
هذا بشبه يعني حقيقه ليس اجتماع سياسي بل
اجتماع كرنفالي حقيقه عندما نشاهد ان من
حضره من وزراء خارجيه فقط وزير خارجيه
العراق التي اصبحت محافظه ايرانيه
وبالاضافه يمكن الى وزير خارجيه زمبابويه
وما ادران ما زيمبابوي بالاضافه لمجموعه
من السفراء اهمها وابرزها كزاخستان
قزاقستان طجكستان تركمنستان وكانه يعني
حقيقه مؤتمر يحق ان يسمى مؤتمر ستان بدل
ان يسمى اي شيء اخر عباره عن مجموعه دول
وصفوها بانها دول مؤثره بالشان السوري
كثير منهم ربما لا لم يسمع بسوريا او لا
يعلم اين سوريا على الخارطه بالنسبه لهم
هم بعيدين كل البعد عن الشان السوري وكل
ما خرج عن هذا المؤتمر يتناقض ل بالقول
وبالفعل بما ما تفعله ايران فمثلا المؤتمر
يقول عن حل سياسي بينما نفسه صالحي منذ
ايام قليله عندما كان وزير خارجيه مع
النظام المعلم في طهران قال ان الحل
السياسي هو وهم والانتقال السلطه هو وهم
وهم اليوم يقولون انتقال سلطه وبنفس الوقت
وبنفس الوقت اذا لاحظنا انه ايام قليله
كان جليلي التقى مع بشار الاسد في لقاء لم
يكن فيه ولا واحد سوري سوى بشار الاسد
العميل الايراني والباقيين كلهم ايرانيين
اليوم ترافق بعد هذه الزياره وبدء هذا
المؤتمر اليوم ترافق مع قصف
كبير لحلب واقت ومحاولات لاقتحام مدينه
حلب هذا هو الحل السياسي الذي تروج له
ايران بالاضافه استاذ ابراهيم سميت دولا
عده وقلت متهكما طاجيكستان وكل هذه الد
دول ولكن ايضا المعارضه السوريه شارك
شاركت في مؤتمرات عده كان فيها دول بعيده
عن سوريا ولا تعرف شيئا عن سوريا وانت
ادرى بها ولكن كان عددها يا سيدتي ليس 13
او 30 دوله 133 دوله هنا الفرق الكبير نحن
لا نتكلم فقط من باب التقليل من قيمه تلك
الدول ولكن عم نتكلم بوزن سياسي فعلي
حقيقي ونتكلم مقارنه بما صرحت به وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه قبل المؤتمر وكانت
بسميه مؤتمر للدول المؤثره ذات الوزن على
سوريا فتبين للجميع ان حتى روسيا والصين
اصدقاء ايران لم يكن لديهم الوقت الكافي
يرسلوا اكثر من قائم اعمال او دبلوماسي من
الدرجه الثانيه او شبه سفير ليحضر هذا
الاجتماع بالسه لما خرج عن هذا المؤتمر هو
هو رد مبررا لان هذا سما جعلوه تشاوري
جعلوه تشاوريا عندما لم يجدوا اي طرف مهتم
بالنداء الايراني لانهم يعلمون ان ان
ايران هي طرف اساسي لا يمكن لشخص ان يكون
خصم وبنفس الوقت حكم وهذا هو حال
الايرانيين وعندما يتكلمون مثلا عن العنف
يدعمون النظام بالحرس الثوري يدعمونه
بالسلاح وبالمال وبكل هذه الاطراف ويريدون
من الشعب السوري ان لا يدافع عن نفسه ح
حلال عليهم وحرام علينا ان ندافع انفسنا
هم وهم وحزب الله س ساعود اليك سيد غسان
ابراهيم دكتور هل لك ان تفصل في هذه
المشاده و
تقول لنا ما اهميه هذا الاجتماع التشاوري
في طهران يعكس مدى رغبه دول الجوار لتدخل
ايران في النزاع السوري الحالي طبعا هذا
يعكس ايضا مدى ضعف ايران في المنطقه ومدى
عدم رغبه معظم دول العالم التعامل مع
ايران كداه حل لاي مشكله دوليه لان ايران
والجميع يعلم بان ايران هي جزء من المشكله
وليس جزءا من الحل ايضا ذلك يعكس لماذا
فشلت خطه عنان عنان منذ البدايه ركز على
طهران على انها محور مهم جدا في حل هذه
المشكله نرى بان ايران اليوم تدعو الى
مؤتمر ل للمصالحه او تدع لمؤتمر للحل
بالنسبه او تشاوري بالنسبه لسوريا ولا
يجيب طلبها اكثر من 30 او 13 او 15 دوله
ذلك يعكس مدى الدور المهم او غير المهم
التي تلعبه ايران في اي مشكله دوليه خاصه
المشكله السوريه هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
ثانيه اعتقد بان الجميع سئم دور ايراني
السلبي في هذه المشكله بمعنى حينما يذهب
مسؤول الامن القومي الى الى دمشق ويستقبل
فقط من من قبل الرئيس ولا يكون هناك اي
انس اي شخص اخر مع الرئيس لاستقباله يعني
منافي منافيا لكل بروتوكولات العالم
استقبل الرئيس بشار الاسد لاريجاني فقط مع
ثمان ايرانيين وهذا لم يكن يعني في اي
دوله من العالم من قبل من قبل تقصد ممثل
خام مثل نعم نعم ممثل خامنئي ذهب الى الى
الى الى دمشق او الى ملجا جليلي الى الى
دمشق او الى ملجا لا نعري لا نعي او لا
نعرف اين استقبل هذا الرجل فقط استقبل من
قبل الرئيس بشار الاسد ولم يستقبل من قبل
وليد المع وكن ه هذا مؤشر على دور سلبي
لايران يعني هي تدع للحوار اين السلبيه في
ذلك نعم السلبيه في ذلك هو بان الملف هو
ملف امني ايران لا تثق باي مسؤول سوري على
الاطلاق سوى بشار ايش هو بشار الاسد اعتقد
ايضا بان ايران ترسل رساله مفادها بان ال
الصراع في سوريا الان اصبح عقائديا وليس
سياسيا المعظم يجمع على ان ومن ومن ضمنهم
الملك عبد الله الثاني ملك الاردن على ان
الصراع بين الشيعه والسنه هو صراع سياسي
ليس ديني اها حينما يجتمع الايرانيين
والرئيس السوري فقط هنا ذلك دلاله هام
لذلك دلاله هامه وهي بان الملف عقائدي
وليس سياسي اعتقد هنا يعني تكمن
المشكله بالشيعه يعني هنا يعني ايران ترسل
رساله مفادها بان الملف هو ملف شيعي الامن
القومي الشيعي مهدد في المنطقه ايران سوف
تحمي الملف الشيعي في المنطقه ولو ذلك كلف
كان هنالك تصريح يعني انه لن يسمح بكسر ما
سماه محور المقاو ما هو اي مقاومه هو
يتكلم عنها ما هو ايضا ذلك يعني يعني
يستهل الاجابه من مثل هذا الرجل اي مقاومه
يتكلم عنها مقاومه الشعب السوري للنظام
السوري او مقاومه النظام السوري للشعب
السوري لم نرى الدبابات السوريه الا في
وار حماء وحلب ودمشق لم نراها على الاطلاق
في اي في اي مسرح دولي على الاطلاق لذلك
يعني هذا مهم جدا ايضا ايضا يوجد رساله
موجهه لايران من روسيا والصين بانه يعني
نعم ممكن ان نعتمد عليكم في بعض الامور
ولكن ليس في كل الامور انتم ليسوا طرفا
هاما على الاطلاق في هذا المحور ولن نسمح
لكم بان تكونوا حدا في حل هذه المعادله او
او او او ضلعا في حل هذه المعادله لذلك
يعني كل الاشارات تدول على مدى ضعف ايران
في في الملف السوري ومدى عدم رغبه اي دوله
من دول الجوار لان تكون ايران لديها اي
حلقه مهمه تمسك بها او اي خيط مهم تمسك به
في هذا في هذا الملف ويعكس ايضا ويعكس
ايضا ضعف الطروح الايرانيه هم يتكلمون عن
حل سلمي
ويدعمون الرئيس السوري او يدعمون النظام
في دمشق بالادوات العسكريه وبالات
العسكريه لذلك يوجد تناقد كبير بين ما
يقولون وما يفعلون طيب ساعود اليك دكتور
وساعود ايضا الى ضيفي وهل سينجح شماع
طهران في توفير ما دعى اليه من حل سياسي
للازمه السوريه سنناقش ذلك بعد فاصل قصير
فابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي
تتناول فرص ال نجاح اجتماع ايران التشاوري
في حل الازمه
سوريا سيد نعيمي ضيفي من طهران الدكتور
شباني يرى بان مستوى الاستجابه لهذا
الاجتماع التشاوري وطريقه عقده تعكس مدى
ضعف الدور الايراني وعدم رغبه اي احد في
التعامل مع ايران ما
ردك يعني في الحقيقه يجب ان نكون واقعيا
نحن ننظر الى المؤتمر التي اقيمت من اجل
سوريا من باريس الى اسطنبول الى الدوه كل
المؤتمرات كان نتيجتها التحريض على قتل
الشعب السوري وت بالسلا في ايران لم يكن
مثل هذا الشيء
المرات هنا
طباجه المت التحريض رايت تحض المؤتمرات
السابقه معروف بدات كل المؤامرات على
سوريا بدات من هذا المؤتمرات تسليح
المسلحين
ودخول يعني اجازه حرب مسلحه نرى الان من
المؤتمرات التي ذكرتها الان لم تخرج ببيان
يقول فيه ندعو الى التسليح اي من هذه
المؤتمرات يعني ايضاحا للمشاهدين ايضا اي
من هذه المؤتمرات
لم تخرج ببيان
يقول بالتسليح وبتحريض وبقتل السوريين
لذلك وجب التوضيح سالناك عن مساله
الاجتماع التشاوري كلام صالحي يقول علينا
انهاء العنف في الوقت ذاته يسلح النظام
السوري وحتى بعد لقاء الاس
بجليله بدون حضور بروتوكولي لاي من وزراء
او او احد الدبلوماسيين زاد عنف النظام في
حلب الكبيره التي تقيم الشعب السوري مع
الاسف الشديد في هناك بعض الاطراف العربيه
ايضا معها نعرفها جميعا كما قلت منذ
البدايه المؤتمر تهران على الاقل طالبت من
جديد بحل سلمي وليس هناك اي طريقه لحل
سوريا الا بطريقه السلميه والا التدبير
كما تريد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكما
تامرها السيده
كلينتون ولكن لم تجبني النظام الايراني
يقول عبر صالح اليوم انه يريد انهاء العنف
في الوقت ذاله في الوقت ذاته يسلح النظام
السوري وبعد لقاء الاسد ب جليلي زاد عنف
النظام في
حلب لا لا لا ما في هنا هناك هناك مسلحين
يار اي
دوله للاسف سيد نعيمي حتى يعني نحل مشكله
الصوت
هذه انتقل الى ضيفي من لندن السيد غسان
ابراهيم سيد
ابراهيم سيد نعيمي سيد نعيمي تسمعني
الان عم بسمعكم بس انتم بتقوا ما بعرف لا
ادري هل هل كلامي تفضل تفضل لسنا نحن من
نقطعك وجهتنا مشكله تض ان اقول بواقعيه
ليس دفاعا عن الحكم السوري وليس دفاعا نحن
خلي نكون واقعيين هل تدمير سوريا الان وهو
ليس لمصلحه اسرائيل ماذا نقون الان يجب
الدول الدول التي تصاعد وتحرض المعارضه
على العنف يجب ان تجاوب نحن لا نقول ان
الشعب السوري هي التي يجب ان تحكم بنفسها
يجب ان تنقل يعني يكون النقل السلطه بشكل
سلس ليس بتدمير سوريا التي تمزق سوريا
وع
الىع
تد لا اعرف لا اعرف كيف يمكن لنا ان نقبل
مثل هذا الشيء وكلما تحدث ان يكون ايران
في المعامره وذلك في المعامره يعني ايران
ماذا فعل ايران منذ البدايه طلبت ان تبقى
سوريا سوريا وحدتها وحده
اراضيها وتسلم السطه الا ترى الا ترى اي
خطا اقترف من جانب النظام السوري الم
يعترف بشار الاسد شخصيا بان الاشهر السته
الاولى لم يكن فيها سلاح الا الا ترى هنا
في عين الناقد يعني لو لو حاولت ان ان ترى
ببعض النقد طريقه تعاطي بشار الاسد مع ما
جرى في بلاده الا ترى شيئا خطا
ابدا انا انا لا ابرر احدا انا اقول الذين
هم من وراء من وراء الجدار يحكمون على هذا
المسار هم ليسوا من يعني لديهم الصلاحيه
بهذا الشيء لانه كما قلت هناك معسكرين يقف
كما نعرف جميعا الان اسرائيل والله تصفق
لما يجري في سوريا هذا ليس لمصلحتنا لا
لمسحت لمسحه العرب ولا لمسحه اي خر فح
استمرار الحرب استمرار التدبير الحل هو
اكيد اكيد في الجلوس الى المفاوضات وحل
سلمي اذا لم تنقل السلطه بشكل سلس في
وقتها المحدد عند ذلك كل حادث حديث وليس
ال
بضري اوضحت وجهه نظرك سيد غسان ابراهيم
اذا اصرار ايراني على انه لا ينحاز وعلى
ان بقيه الدول تتامر على سوريا لمصلحه
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
مرد يا سيدتي في كل مره نقول للايرانيين
ولحزب الله كفوا ارفعوا يدكم عنا لا
تتدخلوا بالشان السوري يقولون لنا نحن
ممانع والمشكله مع اسرائيل يا سيدتي هل من
ي يقتل الشعب السوري هي اسرائيل هل هل هل
هل من يرسل السلاح والمال والقوات والحرس
الثوري الى سوريا هم اسرائيل ايران متورطه
من راس من من من قدميها الى راسها فيما
يحدث في سوريا تعتبرها معركه مقدسه او
معركه مصيريه لها في سوريا الجميع شاهد ان
بشار الاسد لم يتخذ قرار باقتحام حلب حتى
جاءته الاوامر الايرانيه السريه بظرف مغلق
كانت جاءت بيد جليلي ووصلت الى بشار اوامر
عسكريه بالتنفيذ بالتوقيت المترافق مع هذا
المؤتمر الجميع اصبح مدركا ان ايران عندما
تتبجح وتقول في مؤتمرها هذا انها ضد
التدخل الخارجي نحن نسالها هل اصبحت سوريا
محافظه ايرانيه هل اصبح الشان السوري هو
شان محلي ايراني حتى تتولوا امورنا وتتحدث
باسمنا وتعقد مؤتمرات ولكن ماهم هل تريدون
ما الدليل يا سيد غسم ابراهيم ما الدليل
على ذلك واصلا اذا ايران تعاطت بملف سوري
كل العالم يتعاطى حاليا بالملف السوري
لماذا ايران دون
سواها يا سيدتي لا يوجد ولا دوله اخرى غير
ايران ترسل المال والسلاح والرجال ولدينا
48 رجل من الحرس الثوري باعتقال تحت يد
تصرف الجيش السوري الحر وتحت وهناك المئات
من الحرس الثوري هم تحت مراقبه الجيش
السوري الحر وسوف يتم اعتقالهم وكشفهم
للاعلام هم مراقبون ويتم رصد تحركاتهم
وسوف يتم كشفهم للعلن كما تم كشف بتسليح
المعارضه ايضا في المقابل يا سيدتي نحن
نتمنى لو كانت تركيا تقدم اي سلاح لو كان
يصل الثوار اي سلاح مضاد للطائرات لاحتاج
الجيش السوري الحر بضعه ايام ليصل من
الحدود التركيه الى الحدود الاردنيه مطهرا
كامل البلاد من العصابات الاسديه ما ما
يحتاجه الجيش السوري الحر بضعت صواريخ
مضاده للطائرات وبعض السلاح النوعي لوضع
حد ليس فقط اسقاط اسقاط هذا النظام بل
لقطع اليد الايرانيه في كل الدول العربيه
ابراهيم اختم معك دكتور شباني هذا
الاجتماع التشاوري في النهايه في ايران هو
اجتماع تشاوري هل ترى انه يعني لا نتيجه
له اطلاقا ام نتيجه سلبيه ام الى نوعا ما
نتيجه ايجابيه ما رايك يعني ذ النتيجه بيد
ايران والمحصله النهائيه بيد ايران ان
كانت ايران تريد ان يكون لهذا الاجتماع
نتيجه ايجابيه فلتعلم الى الملا اليوم قبل
قبل غدا بان على النظام ان يسحب معظم
الاليات العسكريه من
الشوارع يعيد كل الجيش الى القواعد ويعيد
كل الطائرات الى المطارات هذا اولا ثانيا
عليها ان تقنع حلفائها في دمشق
ليس خطه عنان بالذات ولكن ممكن ممكن تجاوز
خطه عنان الى خطه ايرانيه بد تكون خطه
ايرانيه حقيقيه لتسهيل الحل ولكن الواقع
هو بان ايران تقول شيء وتفعل شيء اخر هنا
تكمن المشكله منذ البدايه وحتى النهايه
ايران حتى هذه اللحظه موقفها سلبي جدا في
الملف السوري و وخلقت من المحور السوري
محور شيعي بغيض في في في المنطقه واجت
الصراع الطائفي والاثني في المنطقه ولك
مقاومه ومانعه ول الشيعي مقاومه من و
وممانعة
دعم حماس قسم الشعب الفلسطيني ورسخ
الانقسام بين الشعب الفلسطيني اكثر من شيء
اخر تدخل ايران في ملفات الاقليميه في
المنطقه اجج الصراع على عده محاور في
المنطقه ولم يس عقائدي طائفي و وبالنسبه
لتوازن القوى اعاد توازن القوى بصوره
خاطئه جدا اججت من الصراعات الطائفيه
والعسكريه في المنطقه شكراك شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور غسان شباني رئيس قسم العلاقات
الدوليه في جماعه مرموت الامريكيه ايضا
اشكر ضيفنا من تهران مصيب النعيمي الكاتب
والخبير في الشؤون الايرانيه وايضا اشكر
من لندن غسان ابراهيم المعارض السوري
المستقل ومدير الشبكه العربيه العالميه
للدراسات واشكر متابعتكم الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء